[Music]
this is star talk explainer edition
neil degrasse tyson here your personal
astrophysicist guy with me chuck knight
jack hey hey neil what's happening you
love you those explainers don't you
that's right uh because uh it's the one
time where i don't have to do anything
explain it
and normally when i have to do
explaining i'm in a little bit of
trouble so this is really very
pleasurable for me well we couldn't let
this go by the first images from the
james webb space telescope launched back
chris december 25th christmas morning
2021 yeah uh went out to a million miles
from earth in the opposite direction of
the sun to drink in the universe yeah
all its glory yeah and i know a little
bit about the james webb space telescope
but i'm not on their payroll okay we got
better people than me to talk about this
thing and so we combed the landscape and
we found nicole colon nicole welcome to
star talk hi thanks for having me
nicole you are the correct me if i'm
right here the deputy
scientist for
exoplanets for the web james webb space
telescope that's specific at all
i know it's not a mouthful at all
but that's me that's me that's right
that's you great and where do they house
you uh i am housed uh actually at nasa's
goddard space flight center which is in
greenbelt maryland
right outside washington dc basically
just outside the beltway i guess is that
right
yeah so nasa has i last i counted 10
centers
how many centers care or we all care but
how many centers have direct control
over what the telescope is doing
uh i believe that's one
[Laughter]
you guys control the telescope
nice nasa goddard yeah we play i mean
okay to be fair there are scientists
right at all the centers who are using
of course and around the world of course
yeah absolutely around the world but
goddard manages the project
okay got it and and what about the the
old
sleepy hubble telescope space science
institute
it's so funny when you say that i just
hear hubble just going i'll tell you
what what i was
i remember i remember when it was really
difficult to get images of a deep field
i was the first to do it
let me tell you how we did it in my day
for all these fancy folding
telescopes came along
we did it in the snow
[Laughter]
well and you know what now jwst doesn't
does
what hubble did before breakfast
basically there's a punchline yeah
not too much that's some cold stuff
you need a more polite way to say that
but to be fair yes hubble okay we would
not be here today without hubble right i
mean 30 plus years discoveries that paid
our path that set us up yeah and i see
that poster behind you that's not a
virtual image right that's a real it's
just unfolding the universe has got an
image of of the telescope i see what you
did there i see
we see what you did there tell us what
you did there oh we did that we went
there we are unfolding the universe
because we had to unfold the telescope
to see the universe
so it was because the telescope had to
fit inside of a fairing it's absolutely
launch fairing
and rather than make a telescope as wide
as the mirror that you needed
what did you guys figure out how to how
to do that
well we knew we needed a giant telescope
it's about 21 feet across in diameter
and we knew the largest rockets just
couldn't launch it so we had to fold the
thing up and
yeah and it even then it just barely fit
in the rocket
it reminds me of those planes on the
aircraft carriers that oh yeah with the
wings
that fold up wait but nicole in all
fairness it's not that the telescope
just barely fit
it's that it was designed to just barely
fit because you want to eke out every
millimeter of space for the telescope in
the fairing right absolutely yes we
wanted what is the largest thing we
could build
to
unfold the universe as we say you know
to look at it with our our now what we
have an infrared eye in space and allow
me to say
there would be no astrophysicists on the
frontier of anything we're not for
clever engineers empowering our dreams
is that fair nicole oh yes there have
been thousands i think up to something
like 20 000 people who have contributed
to this project and a lot of those are
engineers and and you know what's what's
sad to me is you know when these images
come out they always interview the
scientists and not the engineers that
most of the engineers are sort of silent
heroes in this effort so let me just
give a a loud shout out to the silent
thousands of engineers who made all this
happen not only within nasa but with the
with the corporate partner uh northrop
grumman and and others who participated
uh so nicole this is a huge telescope
but how big is its field of view
so web was designed really to do
kind of
deep but small images so it's not it
doesn't have a gigantic field of view
actually but it can do really deep
images and see really far back in time
actually so if you wanted to have a big
area you'd have to mosaic
multiple sets of exposures no
no panoramic feature
like my iphone has a background so i can
do that
what kind of cheap ass telescope is this
get steve jobs on the case
i don't know if your iphone can see
galaxies though just whoa
oh oh look at that the gauntlet has been
thrown down yeah first blood drawn right
there blood drawn
nicole remind me where jwst was launched
from
it was launched from a place called
french guiana
and that is french
wait what's the matter space coast
florida is not good enough yeah
jack wizards
we needed this really big rocket right
to launch it and that had to come from
uh this
company called aryanspas so we worked
with them
and that's their launch site so
i didn't get to go to the launch site
but that's okay
okay but other folks did and
isn't that closer to the equator than it
is yeah and so you get that little extra
boost
um because the equator is moving faster
than other latitudes on earth
and if you launch east you get that
extra rotational boost oh that's kind of
cool it's kind of cool yeah it's like
the earth is helping like giving you a
little toss just a little toss that's
exactly right so in what other ways did
other organizations or countries
participate in this
well our two primary partners so besides
nasa it was the canadian space agency
and the european space agency and they
both provided instruments and scientists
to work on the mission with web and now
you know we're here today again 20 000
some people across the globe have
contributed to this project so so nicole
that first image that we all saw which
got leaked
leaked a day before the press conference
because you're fresh off the press
conference at the time of this recording
i saw an image before the press
conference and was shown to me by
president biden
so is that allowed
well i mean i i think if the president
has an ask you probably don't say no
you know he it's it's good news right we
want him
after all right he is he is the
president we are more than happy to give
the president good news to share
yeah he's more than happy for you to
give him that good news believe me but
if if i know chuck he tried to extort
something out of the president for
that's right i don't know yeah like you
know there's certain there should be a
little budgetary bump for you guys
waiting
like right little christmas bonus for uh
look up take nasa's nasa's annual budget
yeah giving the president the
put his day in the sun or his day and
the stars as it were
so that first image nicole i remembered
it was a
it's a galaxy cluster showing distant
galaxies uh gravitationally lensed
around it brilliant first target yeah
for that but there were four other
images is that correct shown at the
press conference yeah yeah so we have
five total targets that were released um
everything came out mid july july 12th
here we are and they covered basically
representations of what webb will do
over the next years to come
and just to be clear
my first understanding of web but
that understanding would be
significantly
grown and modified over the years
because the web has been in the planning
since like the 90s at least
so it was presented as a telescope that
could see the birth of the universe the
birth of galaxies in the early universe
by focusing on
infrared part of the spectrum
but if you do that
infrared is also because here we have
chuck our guest doesn't specialize in
galaxies in the early universe she
specializes in excellent planets so what
so so nicole what has infrared done for
you
i know we've uh exoplanets has risen you
know and we're taking over
it's a hot thing yeah well okay to be
fair right so
when webb was first conceived we
hadn't really discovered exoplanets yet
so exoplanets is a pretty young field so
you couldn't even be on the docket
at the time people first met at these
meetings you didn't even have you didn't
even have a job i know
well
you were completely unemployed
you were like you were like put this
thing up there man i need a job
yeah you know it's it's been a great
journey because we've gotten our message
in there right now that we discovered
all these so we okay so this accounts
for why my awareness has evolved
of what the capacity of the telescope is
because whole branches cottage
industries within the field of
astrophysics have risen up
in the era of the design and
construction of the telescope so this is
a beautiful fact yeah now we can study
so when web was
first being designed we started
discovering the first giant like
jupiter-sized planets and we said okay
cool we can use web to study this in the
infrared because that tells us new
things about these planets and their
atmospheres but then now where 5 000
exoplanets later
we now know one's the size of earth and
we can push
webb to look at those so we didn't know
about any of these tiny planets when web
was designed but just to be clear chuck
yeah she says 5000 exoplanets later
right okay in in 1995 there was one
known exoplanet so it's not an
additional 5 000 to an already
versioning catalog it's 5 000 on top of
zero wow so so nicole one of these
images was like yours or or you in your
in your wheelhouse so which image was
that
yeah so that that's the that's the trick
right okay so we use image but it was
actually a spectrum
so it wasn't a pretty image like you
know you saw these amazing galaxies and
star forming regions and all that right
but
the thing is we wanted these first
images and data to be really kind of
representing what the community will be
using the telescope for in the next year
and that
is what we call transiting exoplanets
and planets that transit we can't
actually take direct images of because
they orbit really close to their star so
we're we're
seeing the effect a planet has on its
star as the planet moves in front or
transits its star so we're seeing the
planet move
but only by measuring how the star light
changes okay we're not seeing the planet
directly so that's the star dims i guess
because it's just sitting in front of it
exactly so so how much can you tell from
a dip in light that's coming from a star
i mean it seems like a very limited
amount of information yeah so that's the
thing right so we say okay we're
watching this planet
block some light from the star then you
add that the planet has an atmosphere
this is really tiny amounts we're
talking about but that atmosphere will
block some of that starlight
and basically cause an extra dip
so we can measure that at like the parts
per million level essentially jesus wow
so it's
ridiculously tiny essentially how do you
know it's not like a sunspot or an alien
vessel or
anything or a dust cloud right or
how do you how do you know
how you know
well the nice thing is we we have
science
okay
nicole
nicole
i'm sorry because you can't do that here
all
right our answer or star talk can never
be
a look at science all right no
what am i going to say all right
it's science
but that's cool but that's the good
thing okay i say that right that's the
best i love that answer
nicole chuck is giving you a hard time i
know but
no you sound like my mama
mom i don't understand everybody else go
to the party why can't i go to the cause
i said so that's why
i said you can't go to the party all
right that's it
cause i'm your mother that's why
okay
let us let us allow nicole to explain
further okay all right go yes so what i
mean right is that we have done
experiments even on earth where we know
we want to look for water we know water
has a chemical fingerprint that's what i
mean by science right so
each molecule
in the universe has a chemical
fingerprint
and
when we look up at a planet in front of
its star we're looking at the starlight
filter through the atmosphere
there's a chemical fingerprint there so
we can use our science right use our
data to say we predict water will be
here in this light
and then we see it or we don't see it
right okay so this won't work if the
planet has no atmosphere
exactly right right yeah so this is so
cool it has an atmosphere yeah so what
so do you do that kind of like spectral
thing and if you see no atmosphere is it
just like like our moon
is it
or or could it be like a planet do all
planets have atmospheres pretty much if
they're big enough yeah if they're big
enough if they have enough gravity
they'll have enough yeah yeah right yeah
they hold on to that because
molecules of gas are fast moving
and they really want to escape but you
have enough gravity it'll hold them
they'll hold you it'll hold you down
yeah
cool yeah so cool so so nicole what
you're saying is your spectra is
sufficiently exquisite der i use that
word
that
whatever molecules in the atmosphere of
the transiting planet are there
they're influencing the starlight
passing through them damn
yeah
at this tiny okay
parts per million levels
i'm gonna tell you right now
that is that's pretty mind-blowing man
that's and you're seeing this from light
years away
yes unbelievable and the image okay so
the data we released today that star is
over a thousand light years away
so it's not even nearby and that's
that's why it's so exciting because and
what's the what's the mass on that or
the the
approximate size of that exoplanet yeah
that planet so it's a little bit larger
than jupiter actually well
i say a little bit it's uh 1.2 or so
times the size of jupiter meaning it's
quite a bit larger than earth and then
what kind of star is it is it like our
star it is yeah it's a star similar to
the sine similar temperature size pretty
normal star as we would say okay so
nicole it used to be that exoplanet
people were just interested in the
existence of exoplanets and how big
their orbits were and how many planets
there were and now you're now you're
looking for life on them right that's a
whole new place to be wow and i guess
back then they couldn't ask deeper
questions than just these basic physical
ones about you know the orbital
properties so you so you owe your
livelihood to the power of the telescope
to answer questions that we couldn't
even ask
back in my day
yeah
yeah we you know every time
we start something new like this we're
going to look at planets that are
earth-sized
we can predict what we'll see but
there's always things that we're not
going to expect and then we have to
figure out what they are
so each image then nicole represented a
branch of study for the telescope's
abilities so i we got one which was the
distant universe early galaxies
um gravitational lensing we have your
spectra of the chemistry of exoplanets
so what were the other three
yes so we have
um a another galaxy image but it was an
in-depth called stefan's quintet and so
it's five galaxies that are
relatively nearby
and they're interacting so that's a
really neat thing there and so you see
stefan's quintet yeah what do you mean
what do you mean by interacting oh so
all galaxies are always moving and away
from each other or moving towards each
other and so this is a grouping where
they
eventually can basically come together
and morph into each other and like strip
each other of stars and whatever to form
a brand new galaxy later on this is a
galaxy hoedown it's a hoedown it's a
galaxy
and what's what's fun about it is when
galax galaxies are extended objects
they're not points of
of gravity they're extended and so when
two galaxies see each other and feel
each other's gravitational forces they
begin to distort each other according to
the strength of gravity
across their their physical size which
is not the same
right because if you're the distant
point that's going to feel a little less
gravity than the point that's close up
and so as a result you get this
shredding of a galaxy as it comes near
another guy it's a beautiful it's like a
beautiful train wreck
um would you agree nicole that they're
gorgeous
yeah
also okay the most mind-blowing thing to
me about that quintet is all the
galaxies behind it too
there's just like the field is
photobombed with galaxies
so okay the ones in front are
fascinating absolutely but then it's
like behind there what the heck is going
on oh my gosh because i grew up you know
because like i said me and stefan's
quintet go way back but in the pictures
of stefan's quintet that's kind of the
only action in the photo
so you're saying
so you're saying
the james webb space telescope
even if your
professional scientific interest is
stefan's quintet
somebody else might be able to use the
data that happened to be in the
background of your image to study
something else
yes
there's just data there's galaxies
everywhere essentially
okay so now we've got three of the
images what are the other two so
there was also an image of
a dying star
so it's a planetary nebula they call it
but it's one of these beautiful it has
like shells of material around it
basically the star has died a star like
our sun
and it has evolved and shed its outer
layers over time and it's created these
like bubbles of material where there's
interactions with gas heating each other
heating other gas up and and spreading
elements out through the universe so
it's like this
beautiful transition of a dying star
and it's feeding the universe now does
that have a colloquial name for it
um
for that nebula it does
because chuck we name our stuff whatever
this thing looks like we name it you
know there's a pac-man nebula out there
did you know that i saw that the pac-man
which i love
what's the dying star nebula well this
one is let me let me guess let me let me
guess
it's called american health care
the american healthcare nebula
it's a well it's a little simpler than
that okay
it's the southern ring nebula okay
not even interesting southern ring okay
but if you look at the image yeah
there's there's a bunch of rings like of
material so yeah i think that's where
the name come from as creative as others
that yeah
okay give me one more image
okay then there's karina this is a
region another nebula yeah with star
formation but this one is like zoomed in
you're seeing
just incredible amounts of gas and dust
like you're seeing through the gas and
dust to see stars forming behind it
and heating up the gas and dust and i'm
telling you you have to look at these
images high resolution online you know
because you can just zoom in for days
and see this material just keep zooming
in yeah something you couldn't do with
hubble you can zoom in a little bit and
that was good in its day
right it was good enough for us i'll
tell you that
we didn't need all these fancy high
resolution pictures we used our
imagination and we make calculations on
pen and pencil
okay so you pity nicole because there's
nothing left for her imagination yeah
she's all there
that's what you're saying yeah oh my
gosh we're not we're not done you know
this is just the beginning
well i love that set of five images and
it's quite the breadth of the what the
capacity of this telescope is and can be
so spend another minute telling me about
the administration of the telescope so
what happens at the goddard uh space
flight center again
yeah yeah so i'm that's where i'm based
at in in maryland and um goddard manages
the project it's actually where the
observatory
was
built in part so we have a big clean
room and that's um
on its journey it basically went around
the country um before it went off into
space uh but its operations like day to
day every day are based in baltimore
maryland up at the space telescope
science institute
okay which is where uh hubble
you know cut its teeth right i mean
that's the that was built i think to
handle the report yeah i remember
correctly yeah yeah so now it's handling
the next big thing so uh hubble is in
the record books for being
uh was it the the most number of
collaborative papers of any science
experiment or any science project uh do
we expect web to exceed that
oh gosh i mean i mean in every metric so
total number of papers total number of
scientists total number of countries
all the important measures that bring
scientists together in the world in
harmonious ways
yeah okay so with web you have let's see
it started over 20 years ago we have
over 20 000 people from across the globe
who have contributed
yeah we have um scientists uh
from all over the globe that will use it
i think
you know that so the design mission
lifetime was five and a half years after
launch but we're looking at way before
10 because the launch was perfect so we
have all the fuel we need to support our
orbit
so we're looking at 10 maybe even 20
years so if you imagine you know how
many astronomers can use a telescope in
20 years and right yeah yeah that's a
lot and by the way one of the lagrange
points of the earth sun and we we have a
separate explainer on lagrange points i
think
yeah we do yeah we did super cool yeah
we did one on that so we don't have to
lose time on that okay yeah so it's very
good now yeah yeah very efficient place
to put a telescope yes and do you
foresee that anyone would go to it for
to as a servicing mission is that is
that in the foreseeable
future for accrued space vehicles yeah
maybe to white wipe down their
reflectors you know
give it a little give it a little
squeegee you know squeegee
you know yeah there's no bugs they got
bugs on it on the way
what is that what is that
everything
every image has something that looks
just like a spider what is that
oh yeah that's the answer
maybe maybe robotic missions one day
yeah robotic missions perhaps yeah yeah
very cool is this one of these
telescopes where all data are made
public immediately or is there some sort
of private time the scientist has who
proposed the observing time
so there is actually a mix
so there's a good set of data that's
only
available or it is available immediately
because we want people to make the most
of it right away to prepare
what they want to observe for next year
you know we only have the first year of
science
set
now we need to think about what we're
doing for year two and so we need to
analyze the current data we have so
there's some data that's that's open
right away that'll come out in a couple
days from now
and then other data will have like a 12
month
we call it exclusive access period for
the team who proposed it to work on it
but then it looks like it's their idea
it's their idea exactly right but it'll
be all be public eventually for anybody
in the world to access
wow cool and so what rate do you think
because the hubble has a
i need the hubble voice chuck
hubble has a website where all the
beautiful pick the hubble heritage site
and so
where all the beautiful images went will
there be such a sight for james webb
i think so yeah between
our nasa websites and the space
telescope website there will be images
galore for years to come
so so this is great uh nicole this has
been delight to have you on uh if you
get some really cool result or you find
aliens can can we be your first uh media
outlet for that
i'll call you up sure thing
yeah just call call me up we will
totally give you front row uh
uh front row exposure because you're if
you're looking at chemistry in the
atmosphere is you're looking for the
possibility of life because some
chemicals are are are like biomarkers is
that what you guys call them
yeah yeah so we're we're you know we're
starting slower slower than that so we
want to first make sure that earth-sized
planets like our size the same size as
our earth we want to make sure they have
atmospheres in the first place and then
we say okay
what can we see in those then we run all
our models and say what does that tell
us are there bias signatures so you keep
saying earth-sized planets is that a
pre-requisite for life i mean can't you
have a planet that it's admitting that
we're completely biased i know yeah
we had a whole telescope looking for
earth-sized planets around sun-like
stars okay am i am i right nicole right
the kepler that so that is total bias
yeah who's to say that there can't be
like you know
a life on a jupiter-sized planet well
that's why neptune-sized planet exactly
that's why we are looking at everything
because we don't know we have to start
with what we know right and then it's we
gotta work from there so you gotta start
somewhere okay so nicole my last
question will this telescope have a
serendipity mode
any new
uh access
to the frontier of the unknown
um often are designed to look for things
that we think will be there
okay that's part that's what creates the
design specs for practically anything
that's built but there might be things
you never thought of
and so does this telescope have a mode
where it just looks anywhere
just in case something shows up that we
didn't even know to ask
well
i think
i think yes is the short answer because
using stefan's quintet as an example we
wanted to look at that grouping of
galaxies and what happened we saw
a countless number of galaxies behind it
right so that's what we're going to see
i think in every data set
there might be a serendipitous discovery
of something
got it got it okay because it's so good
at what it does exactly the serendipity
will come and bite you in the ass when
it's it's something that's going to
happen yeah but when you see the alien
mothership just happen to drift into
view you're gonna you're gonna have a
high res uh image way better than any
navy pilot obtained from an f-18 fighter
fighter jet the alien photo bomb
can't wait can't wait
all right nicole we got to call it quits
there it's been a delight to have you on
uh good luck with this sometimes you
need a little bit of that too as you
know but where can we find more
about what nasa's been up to i heard
naza has a podcast is that right oh yeah
there's uh something called the curious
universe so if you're curious about webb
uh you can go there and hear more about
all the exciting things happening in the
images that came out is it right off of
nasa.gov
yes yes you can go to nasa.gov for all
your resources or other social media at
nasa web as well okay and i tweeted at
web
just a few days ago and the web twitter
address is nasa web i think w-e-b-b
at nasa webb so nasa has has been a
long-time active player in the social
media universe it's good to see them
there uh it's part of what helps keep
nasa relevant and part of our dreams
can't follow that with anything no we
got to end it right there right there
what are you going to do i mean how am i
going to screw up the future with a joke
after that that's right this has been
star talk and explainer the delighted
for nasa to lend us nicole colon give us
some insights into the james webb space
telescope always good to have you chuck
always a pleasure all right neil
degrasse tyson here you're a personal
astrophysicist keep looking up
[Music]
you